Speaker 1: I have to tell you, I don't normally
take great pleasure in this type of thing,
but I took great pleasure in the lunatic
Republican Laura Loomer, sobbing while
claiming that the election was stolen from her by
a Republican. We're going to look at the video in
a moment. It is really something else if you're
not familiar with Laura Loomer. Laura Loomer
was a far right congressional candidate. She was
running first and foremost in Florida in a primary
against Daniel Webster. She ran a primary
against Daniel Webster and she lost the primary.
This is Florida's 11th Congressional District.
Laura Loomer, 29 years old, complete and total
extremist. And she lost and she just she just
lost. There's there's really nothing else to it.
This is a Republican stronghold district. The
Republican Party has received at least 65%
of the vote in the last three elections in 2020.
Loomer won a primary in Florida's 21st District,
but was then crushed in what is an unfavorable
district. If she had won this week, she probably
would have won the general because now she was
running in a very conservative district. But
Daniel Webster won. And there's this incredible
video where she is sobbing and saying fraud cost
her the win. And I have to tell you that to
some degree, I find this absolutely hilarious.
Speaker 2: We are losing our country because
of big tech election interference. And I am
pleading with the Republican Party to please start
taking this issue seriously. Please, because the
American people deserve representation. And
that's that's why I ran for Congress in 2020.
It's why I ran for Congress in 2022. And that's
why I'm going to keep fighting for all of you.
Speaker 3: I never know what to do.
Speaker 1:
Yeah. So she's asking Republicans to stop the
voter fraud in a Republican primary in a red
district completely run by Republicans. So I guess
it's really not Democrats that are doing the voter
fraud. And of course, if you actually confront
them with that and say, wait, you guys spent the
second half of 2020 arguing that it's Democratic
voter fraud that's going to result in the theft of
an election. And it was the Democratic machine
that stole it from Trump and gave it to Biden.
But now they lose a Republican primary and they
use the exact same series of talking points.
So it's Democrats and Republicans, and then
they'll say, Yeah, it's the rhino Republicans.
The Rhino Republicans, which means Republican
in name only. They're not really Republicans.
They are just as bad with the voter fraud.
So but in 2020, a lot of those rhinos won.
But you didn't say there was voter fraud then?
No. Well, in 2020 it was just the Democrats. But
then now it's the Republicans in the primaries.
This is absurd. And it is a great thing that
Laura Loomer lost. Laura Loomer has promoted mass
shooting conspiracies like, for example, claiming
Parkland was staged. The Vegas shooter was ISIS.
She claimed a right winger who was arrested for
having illegal weapons was actually Antifa. She
described herself as a pro white nationalist.
So I think you get it. This is an absolutely,
completely and totally horrible person. And
then she put out a statement on some platform
saying she doesn't concede and it's crazy.
She wrote, I do not concede. And I encourage
all of my supporters and all of my voters
to not support Daniel Webster and the corrupt
establishment RNC. And the big tech voter fraud
machine that is propping his feeble body up and
depriving my constituents of the representation
they deserve and need. I'm calling for Daniel
Webster to resign because everyone knows he is
beyond unfit to serve. You know, I think that's a
message I can actually get behind. If Laura Loomer
is saying in November in the 11th District,
don't go out and vote for Daniel Webster,
you. It's a mostly Republican district. I'm
absolutely fine with them staying home. I would
never advocate for people not to vote. I think
it's not a good thing to tell people don't vote.
But if they want to tell their supporters not to
vote, I am absolutely all for it. It's hilarious
that this is what is going on with Laura Loomer,
and deservedly so. Not that Daniel Webster is that
much better. He's not. He's no beauty, right, to
use Donald Trump's phraseology. But loomer would
have been extremely dangerous. It is a great
thing that she lost. She lost fair and square.